recording in progress
hello everyone uh well we're back after
us some hiatus for our summer school and
summer camp and we are doing language
design review
part of our incremental language design
uh
uh series
all right we've got a variety of topics
sub matrix replace
what is this for
and what is okay
nest wild graph
so we'd originally talked about nest
while graph was something you wanted to
look at and we started putting the
items together for this and i was also
told that okay there was a discussion of
this and it dovetailed with the
submatrix replace function
and
the two of them kind of got squished in
the agenda here charles is supposed to
be here and maybe has joined in since i
peaked but
uh
we wanted these were two things that
i've been getting pinged on that need to
be on the ilg agenda to look at all
right and so we put them to my mind nest
wild graph is just
seems like a good thing so just so i
understand how it works
um
it why on earth is this still wrong here
it's not wrong it's perfectly correct
no we're not i've responded to every
email about it this is not right this
has to be changed
this looks stupid and we got to change
it
okay so figure out how to get it changed
i
let's
figure out how to get a change i know
you have a pusher id and you have an
author name so make sure yeah right so
therefore we need to figure out how
we're not going to have something like
this where the publisher name is the
same as the author name tell people if
they're going to use their name and it's
the same as the publisher name don't use
it
see what i'm saying
i don't think that's a good constraint
well this is not going to work i don't
want to see this again we've been
through this many times figure out a way
to solve this if you can't figure it out
i'll figure it out but that's my
suggestion
what are you objecting to the fact that
the same name is listed twice it looks
stupid
yes exactly
yeah exactly right that's the publisher
that owns the resource and it it's not a
one-to-one relationship it could be
then why don't we say contributed by
and then vertical bar publisher colon if
we really want to say that i'm not
really comfortable with that
but we've got to do something to solve
this
well point out it's not literally the
same name twice
that was a piece of humor it's i right
no
right i mean
right it's bradley versus brad so how do
you expect the
some automated system
the automated system isn't going to do
it the automated system
we've got to tell people not to do this
okay
i mean i assume that there could be some
sort of distinction in the types of
accounts of like this is a kind of
you know if they're basically accounts
for individuals versus accounts for
quote-unquote publishers that's a good
idea well i don't know if they're going
to be cases where for example you know
there'll be something that's published
is from wolf from research
you know like where the creator is
but it can also be an account for an
individual
but
for in here say bradley worked with his
friend samantha and he writes bradley
clee and samantha jones as the
contributor right and it's a single
person publisher account
we'll come back and we'll talk about
this again but please try to solve this
okay
if you really really can't i'll try and
solve it for you but i think you can
solve this
okay so we never end up with something
like this
if it ends up you know even if it says
also for internal people it doesn't make
sense to have them be the publisher well
if they use the wolfram publisher
account we don't even show it but if
you're publishing on your own publisher
account then it's okay
then then we should we need to tag it in
some way
okay
so we don't get this all right let's go
look at this function
i assume we have
bradley here right
uh yes
answers yes okay
i don't know whether it's brad or
bradley now
is fine
it's an equivalence class
um
okay
okay
okay so on every tentacle it goes on
until tests no longer is no longer true
is that correct
well i think it works pretty much
similarly to nest wild the way that i
understand this one
is that it's just a wrapper for nest
while in the same way that nest graph is
just a wrapper for nest
okay i want to understand that with more
precision if the tentacles
down here to the right okay so let's
let's imagine that i say
uh
help me out here i think the testing
function applies to the whole graph
doesn't it not to the uh
surely it should i mean well well it can
because
in like with nest while
you can specify
in the conditions whether you want it's
a breadth first search and you can
specify how many recent levels you want
to look at
okay so so
why did that do that
i don't understand this isn't that
asking for a for all
was used for the slot there
hash is the whole graph
which is not less than 10
but that's not what we want this
function to do i mean nest graph
takes
right nest graph takes this
and with i guess there's two sort of
right there's an inconsistent thing
that's happening
you know or like nest wild does does two
different things right so first of all
hash in the test for nest while is
generally the same as hash
in uh or hash one in the test is the
same as as hash you know in the
iterating function
and the problem is you can ask for there
to be a hash two hash three hash four
etcetera which would be the previous
you know
the previous n items and so the point is
you can't really represent those i mean
i guess you maybe could in a test
you know for for nest graph where that's
sort of the path that got you to this
point but there might not even be a
unique path so it's kind of
exactly yeah already down the merging in
the nest graph it's already merged
so i i don't think this is right i think
that test should be on every tentacle
test
you know because in in nest right
there's a single thread yeah right
sorry by every tentacle what happens if
you use the what is the fourth argument
you say five right so it gives the most
recent five results to test
that's just gonna be weird well just
pick some arbitrary path back to the
starting position can i interject here
yeah
um if we're talking about testing on
tentacles then i think really more
that's more of a depth first search than
a breadth first search
the way that the breadth first search is
working is like
it's going to take whatever that
iterator is and generate successive
levels and it generates the success
successive levels all at once
the depth first search is just going to
change
right
so it needs it like a tree do we have
our trees people do we have ian here yes
we do have yeah
okay so i should point out that in
recently over the last month while we
were breaking here and doing the summer
school
there is a new resource function
uh depth first search
which then does have testing on the
tentacles
i understand but i i that's good but i
think that the real point here is that
this is actually complicated and depends
on the traversal order
well
not for breadth first search i don't
think but for a depth first service well
it depends what you mean i mean there's
a foliation here you're slicing it at
some level
right well well there's automatically a
foliation because
nest
while it's operating has these stages
that are okay first it it does the first
stage and then it does the same thing
again to every element of the first
stage to get the second stage i
understand i understand understand but i
mean that that although
in a tree that's one thing but some of
that tree element could be equivalenced
with something over here right it could
be equivalence with something at a
different level
see what i'm saying
yeah and there i mean the game graphs
that we did and probably have a lot of
examples look at this this has an
example right here
right see that level
is different from that level
yeah but things like that happen all the
time in the game graphs with the game
graphs the you know
kind of what you're doing with the nest
wild graph is similar to fixed point too
because you can put a condition into
nest wild graph that i guess essentially
does the same thing as fixed point
oh you already had it in there yep
replace
it's fine thanks
okay in future i should open it from
there okay but good thank you for
putting it in there okay so look look
the problem with nest wild graph is
it's a really worthwhile function for us
to have
it's something we've used over and over
again
but
it is unclear what the termination
condition should be because here
we're saying well go at most this number
of steps right and equivalence things i
mean
this
that is you know go a number of steps is
the same thing basically that nest does
so when i when i was making this for the
games post i just said okay we'll do
nest wild graph and make it behave
almost exactly the same
as nest while except that maybe it's
doing a little i i understand but brad
what you're saying is it's not doing the
same thing because there isn't a single
thread of expressions
in nest there's a single thread of
expressions here
the thing that it's applying itself to
is a list of expressions correct
yeah there's one minor difference which
is that
um
these nest graph nest wild graph when
they see a list
in the first argument it assumes that
it's splitting those out on branches
yeah i know i know i know but what it's
doing is the whole point is that the
while
is applying
well you're making it apply to the whole
graph which i think is just i just i
don't know it doesn't seem particular i
mean then i then it's trivial to write
this function i mean this function is
just nest while on isn't it what is it
it's just
it's like a nest iterating function just
calls nest graph at depth one or
something
i guess actually no needs to keep track
of the frontier so
never mind but
right but the thing is okay so what
you're doing here is you're feeding to
the test
the full graph produced so far correct
well i think maybe we should look at
some more of the examples
just answer that question are you
feeding to the test the whole graph
produced so far
yes or you can you know if you want to
you can change it around and say feed it
the last two graphs that you've
calculated no no i understand but it's
the whole graph computed so far right
i i'm just looking at the first basic
example and that's what it looks like to
me because it says go to yes yes
count right yeah
i mean it's not obviously wrong it may
be the only consistent thing to do it's
just what i would assume is that it's on
a tentacle so
yeah so if we wanted on a tentacle my
basic suggestion would be
to look at the other backtrack search
thing and see if we can merge these
functions somehow to have nest while
graph be an intermediary
between depth first searching and
breadth-first searching
right we've been through things like
that before it's complicated it's all
about traversal order again
yeah
right
well
although i'm not sure the traverse order
really matters a whole lot does it i
mean it's basically just each
you know each vertex
is just going to like
here's why it does it here's what it
does think about this if we didn't get
down to this vertex here this graph
would have a different structure
in other words if we only saw
yeah eventually it's going to either see
like like look basically imagine you
have this sort of growing graph
and and at each step you uh i don't know
if nest graph applies to all the
vertices or only the quantity frontier
vertices but but it doesn't even matter
okay you look at all the vertices
um and uh and
and you apply this this function and
then you just
all you do is you say if
this vertex you know satisfies this
condition then i apply this function
otherwise i don't apply the function and
then the version where you care about
history maybe it would be something like
i look at this vertex i look at the
shortest path back to one of the sort of
origin
vertices
um and
yeah but hold on hold on sorry ian said
something
it is only doing it at the frontier
right
next gothic zone no
it's growing it at the frontier i think
because
you apply it too if your functions are
pure then
it might look like it is but it does in
fact apply the operation to every vertex
in the graph
but it doesn't list duplicate edges
like if you if you apply to this
function this to the all the vertices
it seems like you should probably just
be duplicating the earlier edges
right
this is related to this question about
whether it assumes the function is
deterministic
right
which i think we are agreeing it does
right
well i think in the beginning it didn't
so i think the idea is there would be an
option
we are now assuming that it is
deterministic correct
can somebody confirm that please
who wrote this
who wrote what nest goth
who knows okay i thought it was charles
but he's not he's not here so
did we change this so that it is
determined it assumes it's deterministic
we were supposed to
okay where is charles i thought he was
playing i know something something with
nest graph religious was changed
although i don't remember exactly what
i believe we are assuming it's
deterministic
but let's check that could somebody
please track down charles
do i need to i just
just do nest graph with echo and the
function we will immediately be able to
tell
we maybe want to echo hash
so we can see if it hit the same well
actually yeah it looks i mean looks like
yeah the change was made because it
repeats
yeah there are no repeats though
they're there
oh yeah
but this doesn't even change what i was
saying though right because
the point is it doesn't even matter if
it's depth first or breath breath first
all that matters is just you have a test
that applies to a vertex or maybe
applies to a path from the root to the
vertex
yeah and it doesn't matter what your
traversal order is the path you if you
have a vertex you always know what the
shortest path from the root to the
vertex is you're advocating that both
the test and the termination happens
locally
whereas
what's implemented in the function
repository now it's both the test and
the termination happen globally yes well
i i yeah i mean i think i don't know
which is it seems like the local one
will be more useful but i i'm not sure
if the global one actually that could
also be useful can i say two things
actually
if i think that if you test global
you can also test local obviously
and then the second thing is that
why the traversal order matters
if you're look if this is actually a
search and you're looking for some
particular
uh item
then whatever heuristic you put in there
to do the
traversal orders
will determine how long the search takes
and those heuristics yeah yeah yeah
right it's a huge field of optimism yeah
yeah yeah we know we know well okay
the two things look if you if you can
control it globally i don't think that
means you can easily control it locally
i mean you can with some effort but but
the point is if you control it locally
you can do things where this side keeps
growing but this side stops which you
can do by modifying the first argument
of the nest graph but i don't think you
could do it by modifying the third
argument in the global case
yeah i agree
hold on would nick like to make any
comments
uh
in regard to that what
about what behavior okay so what i'm
advocating here is that nest wild graph
look at
locally at the nodes
to determine whether to terminate
now
you know maybe we should table this
until we've got more multi-computation
functions working
because this is precisely one of those
functions it's like theorem proving
right nest wild graph could be thought
of as a theorem prover
nest wild graph it's like you're trying
to reach a particular result
and you're going to make the graph
until you reach that result
yeah but if we're talk if we're talking
about just one result that really sounds
like what's going on no no no we're not
just talking about one result we're
trying to we're trying to make a
function which is a general function but
the point is that if what matters is
whether we you know if we want to prune
it locally on the nodes
that's
for example because we have a single
result we're aiming for that will be a
thing to do
right if you had a single result you're
aiming for that's one where you'd want a
global condition
um
that's actually a good example of a case
where you want a global condition if you
want to just grow it infinitely until
you find you know
your theorem that you're looking for
you just need to basically say member
queue of vertex list of g blah blah blah
if you were doing it locally you
wouldn't be able to do that because you
know this tentacle over here has no idea
that that tentacle over there found the
answer i see what you say i see what
you'll say that's an argument for a
global test
right but by i think that's honestly i
think that's a fairly niche use case
because in that case you really don't
care what the graph looks like once
you've done that you just care that you
found a path to the result i mean only
for sort of
curiosity might you want to see the
whole graph so i think the local case is
still much more common
can we have the testis function with two
arguments and receive both the nodes and
the whole graph
absolutely does it terminate the whole
thing if it's true or does it terminate
just just remove that one
i think it's two functions i think it's
nest well graph and nest vertex graph or
something or nest while vertex or
something
you know
i think that's true or
or possibly put an option in there
saying whether how the test should be
applied
no no not a good idea it's we can't
change the global behavior of the
function just for an option but let's
see we have charles here i think is
charles here yes hi okay
so nest graph assumes the function is
deterministic is that correct
um yes in principle yes
okay because it does because it we
should say that in the documentation
right and the effect of that is that it
only applies the function at the
frontier as opposed to all the vertices
is that right
charles
yes i'm just thinking when you set the
frontier what do you mean
as it continues to nest
it only
applies the function to nodes to which
it has not already applied the function
correct
you mean next ruffle
right yes
okay but if it was not deterministic it
would have to apply to everyone again
which i don't think it could really
consistently do right yes
okay
all right fine
so
okay what what i'm trying to understand
partly from nick here
is whether we are just making a junior
version of these various
multi-computation functions
and we should not do this or whether
this is a simple case that we want to
have independent of having the general
multi-computation functions
nick can you comment on that
uh yeah it's a junior case
i would like to like
more local condition if you if you ask
me
it's like i imagine that it's like just
scrolling a bunch of crawlers
generating a graph and you just
specify a condition where for each of
them to stop
okay but i understand that but multi-way
graph
is something which is essentially the
same
as nest graph is it not
it doesn't have discrimination condition
i'm not i'm saying yeah multi-wave
yeah
multi-way graph is the same as nest
graph but has but keeps a bunch of
additional information correct
like tagging
for example like tagging and branch
shield graphs and causal graphs and so
on
yeah basically if that contains the
information about events
everything else is
also computable
although i think there's value in having
it like very mechanistic simple function
as opposed to sort of asking people to
use some
i don't know i agree
with an intimidating name
well forget that function is not a
built-in function yet we want it to
become so but it isn't yet
and so the question is
in i mean it's like it's like how we
used to um before block map existed you
could do the same thing using
uh the pure function rules of cellular
automata
right crazy and and it's like it's like
and but that was the explain oh we don't
have this function because you can just
do it through cellular automaton but but
that's
you know it's true but it's crazy
yes i agree but but just so i understand
from the nest graph alone which is the
same as multi-way graph
one could compute the branchial graph
purely from
this graph right nick
yes obviously
right depends on definition
there's a function on a wfr which should
do that already
we used
we've used it for the games post
but but the question is it's assuming a
certain breadth-first traversal order
right it's assuming that you're going
you know is it not
no you can specify the foliation
if you want to
so you're saying there's something here
yeah and i used it actually to lay out
some results i got on polynomial
polyamino puzzling too
okay well hold on branchial grafts
is this the one
yeah try i think so
it doesn't take affordation right
no the foliation is optional but it
it um
creates a list of layers of vertices if
you
give it if you don't give it a foliation
as an option it assumes the minimal
foliation
and then that my definition is in vertex
stratify on the wfr too
okay so this is
so this here
very exciting but is is the
branchial graphs
for this i don't know quite why it needs
to have the list here okay so what what
is the what is the way of specifying
takes an additional option of this form
thus the vertex and subset i see that's
pretty nice actually
thanks
ian do you understand how this is
working
do you understand what this is
okay i think you should understand it
because this is this is basically giving
a list of vertices that are considered
to be the successive time steps
right so in general what this is doing
is it's showing you
which
you know the branch oil graph is telling
you
for these two nodes here because they
have a common ancestor they should be
connected
those kinds of things right
if if they're on the same foliation
level
that's correct that things on the same
in the same
layer of the foliation should be
connected if they have a common ancestor
so what we're defining here which is
perfectly nice
is
and perfectly general i think
is what the success of foliation levels
are
yeah and that's a combinatorial problem
that we also solved and discovered
something about rigidity of graphs that
there are certain graphs directed graphs
which are rigid with regard to the
foliations but most of them are not
so that ultimately you get
a lot of different options
for the particular foliation without
having to change the overall length of
the time axis
yes but i mean how would we typically
find
you know in this graph how do we
typically find
is it the vertex yeah it's the vertex
out component
of the root node at a certain level
would be the naive foliations correct
well if you just look at vertex stratify
on wfr
that will pretty much allow you to
calculate them all in a pretty well
ordered way
i don't really quite understand what
this is doing
okay so if i say vertex status by this
thing
okay so what is that doing that that's
basically just doing the levels here
but why is that not the vertex out
component
it's a table of the vertex
out component
am i wrong here
okay i understand why those are
different
can you explain
i think the reason is because like
when you get to vertex four probably
it needs to have two and three as an
input
so it can't be listed on the same level
as three
basically you can't have
the foliation having the same time like
separated vertices
okay
to what extent should we have functions
that are for dealing with post sets
where we just just you know these are
basically anti-chains is that not
correct
the other pre-existing function that
this is similar to
is uh find graph partition
but the wfr function no no it's built in
but it it's built into the language but
it's not complete currently
i've never heard of it
roger says that this is a really
important function i kind of i think
he's right about that
charles can you say what this is
well so craft partition uh essentially
partition your graph in a
equal
you know
you know approximately you know equal
size part where essentially we try to
minimize the number of edges between the
different parts and you use that a lot
in terms of like um
you know partitioning job in the pilot
computer right you want
communities and things like that is that
right
yeah um
it fall more in that category but this
one is more about essentially the weight
on your edges so you can actually
partition
is an optimization problem right so you
want to minimize
the the transfer the communication in
you know equal size part or in your
graph
i understand i think it's a little
different from what we're trying to do
here
um
okay so look
okay we've got several different
questions here first question is do we
want i think we want a nest wild graph i
think as christopher says
despite the fact that it may be a
special case of multi-way graph
it's um
you know
there's value in having that simple
function so now the question is does it
have a local criteria or global criteria
the global criterion is certainly more
general
which
is an argument for it given that this
function
is
you know and this function
nest wild graph
would be essentially a fundamentally
breadth-first operation
wait sorry did you say that the local i
don't think not either the local or the
global constraint is more
general
there there there are cases that that
are different that one can do and the
other can't do for both directions
fair enough okay well let's imagine
that we had a nest wild graph that is
the global constraint
okay
where it's
you know function
init
and then
you know then the same arguments as nest
while make sense
now what would we call the other one so
okay so that that that
it's the same arguments as nest while
where
this test is always applied to the full
graph
really what it is it's
this is not the actual names but but
really what it is it's nest craft while
versus nest while graph they do so nest
graph while is you keep running nest
craft until you know until this
condition globally holds versus nest
wild graph which is like you're running
nest wild on all these paths yeah still
right everyone will understand that
right away yeah exactly it'll be very
understandable no one will be
confused right okay
right so i think nest graph while
is the right name for the thing that's
currently implemented in the function
repository
comments from people
now then then the question is what will
we do
i'll make a comment the reason i called
it nest while graph
is because graph is the output
i change your point but while is not an
outputting thing
it's a reasonable argument but okay so
given that we have these two functions
to name you know
this nest graph while i think we on can
understand that that is just doing the
same as nest graph but with the while
and condition
so now what on earth would this be
called
i mean we could use the names you know
local and global
but it's a little weird it's weird a
long
vertex would be the um
but it might not just apply to a vertex
it might well i don't know if we're
going to support the fourth argument
nest vertices while
where can the global test just
have an additional argument for
particular path
where it is currently at
in addition to the global graph
it's like a supplied function so you
just use false as the third one if you
wanted to do all local you would just
have false as a third argument well
you're you're talking but by the way why
isn't supplied in our agenda that's like
one of the most you know these are some
really important things because supplied
will get us out of this box
i mean supply is also something that's
being actively discussed in lcc it's
it's not entirely contained to one thing
fine yeah um
right there's already something a little
bit like it though and nest while and
that's why i list because there's uh
i think it's the fourth argument is the
number of
of slots to feed into the the function
isn't it yes it is
yeah but i think that nest while graph
has something similar where if you
supply that
the m variable most recently i know
right it gives you the last 10 grabs
yeah the results in this case are the
last m graphs
right
yes
i'm just thinking if we had a combined
function that supported
both the local and the global and and we
also wanted to have
to be able to specify an m for the local
case
then it's not totally clear what the
argument structure would be to that
function of the argument be an
association with keys like graph uh let
me point out let me point out we've got
two things going on here the horror of
breadth first search a very unusable
function we do not want to end up with
that
because we've got some of the same
issues there you know brett first search
skin
um
yeah this to me is unusable i mean i've
never used it
well when when i was implementing the
depth first search i did figure out how
to use depth first scan and compare them
well
well it is i mean when when we added
this what we call actually graph
programming right
is more depend of what people actually
want to use so this was more a more
general open-ended function
right and we we should probably
specialize it and provide some more
special cases
but this kind of gives you that
general abstract way to actually
manipulate it i agree i'm not i'm not
convinced about the design of the thing
i didn't like it when it was first
presented and i still don't like it it's
really complicated
i think it's just that breadth first
scanning you know
algorithms you know
do
they keeps different algorithms keep
different information and they you know
they care about different things and so
it has to be this big floppy function
well maybe supplied is the way out of
that box
is that possible
yeah maybe because i think i think the
main complication comes from which uh
you know what information do you have to
give uh
you know to give to the scanning
function
no you see the scanning function are
more kind of a feedback function the the
function by itself right you don't
actually need to give up those event you
will you know the best bread first can
is
just work
right is now you know while you are
traversing the calf what do you want to
get that's the question
right maybe it's the way we document it
that we you know we kind of emphasize
the event first
and it's what confuse people but you
know we can just drop the event and say
okay well now when you traverse you
cough you can get information about you
know
okay i mean what is the default
i don't quite understand why that why
that isn't an association it's the third
argument of breadth first scan
it was um 10 years before association so
we can convert it to that okay okay but
then if we did that
then
i'm trying to think then then you know
i mean
breadth first scan was just to function
as the third argument without that list
does that work or not
um it should work the first two
arguments should work principle
actually just even one argument
okay so if we say what does it do in
these in these cases
so you just do a breakfast crown and
return you the actual
predecessor right so which gives you the
tree
what the hell does it have to do with a
tree
i mean so as i'm concerned a breadth
first scan is beating some function
i mean and i don't understand why the
function isn't first could scan would
have the function be first
i think i think a breath first i mean
the tree is basically just that a
breadth first scan defines a spanning
tree on the graph you know where the
each node is labeled with you know the
index and when it when it was visited
something like that
okay
that's lovely but that's very similar to
one of these graph stratification things
and that is not what i would expect to
function called so this is this is why
i've been irreducibly confused by this
function probably because i thought a
function called scan
was actually somehow going to i mean you
know to to my mind there is something
that is essentially graph map
just like we have tree map right
that takes a an f
and somehow walks through a graph
applying f to its nodes
if i'm not wrong
but i don't know what the result of that
is i mean in other words maybe that's
silly because in the case of tree map
the tree has a payload at every node to
which it can apply the function that if
i'm not mistaken
i mean you could there could be
something i mean there are times when
i've wanted to have a vertex map
that that that you know takes the graph
and a function and returns a graph
but
i mean part of the thing is
isn't it vertex request
we see here
i mean we we follow at the time you know
we try to map our usual conversion but
here is more a traversal that concept we
don't yet have more general in the
language is you have an expression or
a graph
and you just traverse it
he's a visitor pretty much
right right right so
one possibility for a traversal would be
a list of nodes
you know either the names or the you
know the names of the nodes basically a
traversal is a list of of nodes in some
order which is what for example in this
vertex stratify that's an example
of a an anti-chain a sequence of
anti-chains
that correspond to a traversal of
visiting order for nodes
right
yes and the equivalent for the breadth
first scan or this function this
traversal is when you specify the
visitor function to be discover vertex
okay let's try it
sorry i i'm just that the blah noise is
is um
because i think it's very obscure okay
so how do we do this now
what's s
um so as you can
so s you can put one is the good vertex
you can put discover vertex
goes to
and then if feedback you can see print
or echo or something
i don't really like that i mean that's
going to go okay
which what's that
it's a three argument echo
yes so it
do like to echo of a list
what do you mean
do echo at star list
okay what are we seeing here
so the
so the first the first argument
is actually the vertex is actually
traversing you discover
right and the second argument is the
predecessor
and the last argument is the level in
your traversal
so how does that relate to
so why are there only three levels here
i see four levels at least here
so this is zero one 2 3 4.
so in this case if i said
the vertex stratified name
okay i'm now confused
this vertex stratified says one two i
see one two three
okay is that right so wait a minute
that's level two
i don't understand this this says four
is on level two
well so 4 is a distance 2 from the start
vertex which is what breadth first scan
does
vertex stratify looks like it's
basically a level specification
where you have to take a max
i don't understand that i mean so
vertex satisfies the anti-chains correct
or four is at both a distance two and a
distance three
yeah so the brett's first search takes
the min while the vertex stratify takes
the max
right
it's like how negative levels you you do
the
the highest maximum level of your
children
yeah yeah right why is vertex stratified
why is it sensible for it to take the
max
because um
you also want to input this function to
directed acyclic evaluate
and in that case you need to have all of
your input satisfied before you move on
to computing something on the next node
okay let's understand for other people
what direction they a cyclic evaluator
is
i think
i am utterly unconvinced by its name
sorry
about the name
i like the functionality okay so for
people's benefit
what this does why on earth is that so
complicated there
oh my gosh what is all of that doing
i thought it was doing go ahead
sorry what were you saying
brad what were you saying
hello
we can hear you brad might have got
disconnected
i think most of it is just constructing
an actual graph i know i don't
understand why it's there so we just
feel like
like
put there in place
the argument as a graph
no but look there seems to be a hash
sign there
oh what is all this
you just evaluate this graph in place
and if that would be a better example
brad are you back now
yeah i got booted or something i don't
know
why does this not work i was doing
evaluating place o because i have to do
the whole thing
all right this is really confusing this
is really confusing i'm putting the 10
there right
forget all the stuff
and now i've got a graph here
okay so now what does this do what does
it do when it says evaluate that
what does it do
i thought what it was doing was yes
something like this where you start with
a given thing and then it
it has a function that it applies
doesn't it yeah that the default
function is path count and the path
count on graphs like this just basically
does linear because it's a super super
confusing example i'm sorry you really
should change this example
example is just unbelievably confusing
something much simpler okay so the path
count happens to recapitulate
these these things here
yeah i think there's probably a theorem
that says something like for any linear
recurrence you can always make a graph
structure in which the path count
will tell you the the linear recurrence
on the nodes
okay fine
yeah it's nice but okay look okay
practicality here we've got some other
topics we need to cover today but we
really need to
okay so
i think we need a custom meeting about
graph scanning
um and to me
you know we're going to need to
introduce a collection of functions and
nick i think this is very much on you as
well
um a collection of functions
that
that implements some of the multi-wave
functionality or basically all the
multi-wave functionality in the end
but that also have easy to use things
like nest graph while
and also i mean i really like the way
that
the
what is it the the thing oh my gosh the
thing that has the possibility of having
foliations in it is that necessary or is
that something else
what what allows the foliation option
oh branch of thought yeah yeah that's
the one yes okay but but this directed a
cyclic evaluate on the next version that
we make should probably also allow
foliations
okay can you explain to people what is
directed at circlic evaluate
well i mean the the
the fast fourier transforming example is
probably the best one that's in there
just explain what it is if you have a
graph that describes some sort of
computation where
you have different values calculated
over the vertices and the directions of
the edges tell you how those
values get sent through the graph then
you can also specify a function
on on vertex
that tells you what to do with the
inputs before it sends them out as
outputs right so so
does it send out the output does it send
out the same output to all the tantic
all the all the outgoing edges in the
graph or not uh yeah i think so
yeah okay so if it had multiple ports
this would be very much like the a net
graph type thing with multiple ports
where it brings in it's basically the
the flip way round of an evaluation
graph if i'm not or a trace graph if i'm
not mistaken ian can you comment on that
where it's taking in values where every
node has a value and it's taking in
and every vertex is computed from
similar to tree fold um
the difference is tree fold is
it's basically bottom up and this is top
down
and this is for graphs
right so it's basically giving the data
flow of values from vertices how they
feed into new vertices based on a
function applied to previous vertices
and what is not obvious is for a graph
that's like a cyclic graph obviously
that doesn't work this only works for a
dag
yeah that's one of the main problems we
have right now that i think we'd really
like to solve this problem in the
multi-computational paradigm how to do
the cycle truncation and get
effective computations out of graphs
that have lots of loops in them
well i think that's another one of these
foliation problems
yeah yeah it is kind of and i talked
about this with one of the summer school
students recently too who was doing the
chest problems
and his idea
was just to do put some back tracking on
top of the
the
evaluator there
which that that can work
now the real metallogram doesn't have
any cycles
you only have cycles when you introduce
equivalence between your vertices before
that is just a tree
right so you don't have to do anything
like cycle
what are you doing you've got a
multi-rate graph yeah okay listen we
need to have a separate meeting about
this about graph scanning
okay i think i think it's part of the
multi-computation series which hopefully
will restart again
within this week sometime
let's i'm sorry we really need to take a
look at some of these other things here
just very quickly
um
so this is a topic it may take a little
bit of time but we want to kind of get
to the central point here is
there has been a design ambiguity in the
way we handle temperatures and
temperature differences since we
introduced quantity
yup and
the principal issue is what do you do
when you have an absolute temperature in
a compound unit
so if i have three degrees celsius per
meters
that
temperature can't really refer to an
absolute temperature it's referring to a
rate of temperature change
and so what we've done previously is
just implicitly assume that but because
of various relationships in the unit
framework it creates ambiguous cases
um
like here where if you multiply
boltzmann's constant times the
temperature depending on your choice of
units you can get totally different
answers
and this is something users have noticed
and have complained about because it's
confusing and yes
jose
so if we go down to the list of proposed
changes
there's basically four things that we're
doing the principle one is we're getting
rid of temperature difference units as a
unique dimension
all temperature difference units will be
temperature units
regardless of whether they have a
fundamental michael is michael here
yep he should be
yeah i'll be discussions we have to
cover meetings i think that's very all
very sensible in my opinion
has been removed
okay
because kelvin difference was just
kelvins but in a different unit
dimension because we needed a different
unit dimension previously
so why did we ever introduce temperature
difference units in the first place
or we will still have them we need them
because like you have a
rod that gets expanded to the
temperature the absolute temperature
doesn't matter only the relative ones
matters
like divided by france law even has as
the coefficient temperature difference
divided by temperature so both are
really of other ones
okay so i don't understand where this is
being so you're saying temperature
difference unit no longer exists no no
[Music]
yes so this proposal basically is paying
a lot more attention to the to the
difference between
degree celsius and degrees celsius
difference
and the point is there is no kelvins
difference because it's an absolute
scale yeah exactly kelvins is kelvin the
only reason we had kelvin's difference
before is because we treated them as
distinct unit dimensions which was not
technically correct but was
i see so the dimensions of a degree
celsius is the same as the dimensions of
a degree celsius difference exactly the
only difference between the two of them
would be one has a
effectively a absolute zero base
and the other one has a base at 200 and
some odds so can you take a degree
celsius and divide it by something
because that doesn't seem to make a lot
of sense to me
so the only way you can do that is
effectively by converting it to kelvin
first um so
there's so we'll generate a message yep
so there's a lot of examples here but
basically what we've done is say
if you're doing an operation that is
ambiguous with an absolute temperature
we need to convert to kelvin and we will
give you a warning message about it
because and we will just convert to
colvins we'll just do the conversion yes
right okay and is that a standard
notation that little delta thing there
so that's the proposal
can you increase the magnification but i
can't see those decorations
yeah
so there's basically a delta below the
degree is that michael is that something
the unit aficionados no
so we invented this yes so basically the
standards uh very well say there is a
temperature difference it's not yet
standardized and no own symbol or name
has been proposed
uh medical people use celsius
degrees versus degrees celsius but many
years ago you were strongly not in favor
of that so that's not an option and just
calling it degree celsius as we did
before was massively confusing if the
underlying expression is different
what do you like about people do i'm
sorry what they they put the degree sign
after
the c
oh gosh
that was illiterate
what does it mean
it means they're talking about a change
in temperature as opposed to a
temperature measurement so your
temperature changed when you were sick
by two celsius degrees but you have a
temperature of
you know
37
or
yeah
39 degrees celsius
michael what do you think based on unity
i feel like this is
not acceptable to put the decline to the
right
but having a visual
differentiation i feel like is very
useful and will avoid a lot of confusion
at users okay so the question really is
where do we put it and do we say that
corrects agrees i mean we could turn
that circle
into something that is uh a rounded
triangle for example up there
or is that too freaking weird that might
be too subtle
i don't think it'll be that subtle like
it'll be pretty obvious that's not a
circle
let's see how do we how do we take
normal magnifications
why isn't the trend to the left of the
circle
like delta degrees
to spit to save uh horizontal space
okay
i mean i
i don't like inventing our own character
in general if nobody else has used it
before but we certainly do that on
occasion
so it's not off the table i just think
it's a second best approach to anything
else
no we don't there isn't a standard
approach here
correct
and it is the it is the degree celsius
that is modified it's not a decree that
is modified and not it's the celsius
that's modified to it
so where the modifier should be a little
bit holistic with respect to the whole
thing
all right so do we have this
implementation that if you divide the
degree celsius it turns into
a kelvin or something
that's what we were saying with a
message yeah we have this in prototype
builds um we've been running through a
lot of testing there's some examples
here of
basically all the unit operations you
know this is not
this is not bad that's different thing
go ahead
and if you divide the degree fahrenheit
will it convert to kelvin or terrain can
uh to kelvin so
we
are using kelvin as the base since it's
the the base si dimension we have it's
unambiguous you know rankin or ramier
are
not
widely used and
we had looked briefly at you convert it
into kelvin do the operation and go back
but
the results were often confusing
and so you know there's basic cases like
if you add two absolute temperatures
together you get the equivalent value as
converting them into kelvin
and then
if you
automatically convert them back it looks
a little weird
and so
our sort of central principle was if the
case is going to be ambiguous we want a
message
and when in doubt go to degrees kelvin
or go to kelvins
so
all right so this is
i think that wording is less than
perfect absolute temperature given in
degrees fahrenheit
converting into a difference with that
what what
it's not an absolute temperature what do
you mean by absolute temperature
30 degrees fahrenheit is a temperature
yeah but why does it say absolute
temperature because th that that that's
smacks of kelvins
yeah so i mean the terminology here is a
little tricky but the idea being that
degrees fahrenheit is in an ambient
temperature or
why don't you say temperature given a
degrees fahrenheit
so we want to disambiguate the word
temperature into two absolute
temperatures and temperature differences
okay but i don't understand isn't the
absolute scale of temperature is the one
with kelvins i mean that's the usual
usage
that's the traditional nomenclature yeah
no not really i mean this is the unit
used for it the absolute temperature you
can use with any unit you want
i think the fact that you can convert
between degrees celsius i mean right so
so
in some way to be totally consistent
what you would do is you'd say the
dimensions of degrees fahrenheit or
degrees celsius is this is a relative
temperature and you can't even convert
it to kelvin but because that would be
kind of annoying and crazy and because
you can convert them to kelvin then
you know
where we're calling them an absolute
temperature
right it's not actually relative it's
relative to the zero of fahrenheit which
is itself not absolute in that sense
right right
but absolute temperature is more than a
name rather than saying something is
absolute
it's historical name not a meaning i
know i know but absolute temperature i
thought was the abs usually meant the
absolute scale of temperature can we
just lose the word absolute so it says
temperature given in degrees converted
into a difference
that was what i was suggesting
do we create any confusion by removing
that word as long as we have difference
to contrast it with later on in the same
part of the message
well that's the difference with absolute
zero i don't i
what do you mean yeah i mean it makes
perfect sense stephen right
you've changed three degrees fahrenheit
into
three degrees fahrenheit minus
you know zero degrees kelvin
and that is
all right okay yeah yeah that's right
okay i get it that's right
let's just get some sense here what
things are happening
for example now it's possible to divide
by zero degrees celsius
yes i understand
why does this work
i don't understand what this is doing
that's a that's a degree celsius
oh gosh i'm confused by this so compared
with the next line
notice how unit convert moved
uh if you're not in prototype builds it
will error because of the zero there
yeah
okay but i think if you look at the next
line it's clearer
yeah all three of those inputs are
consistent
unit convert to kelvins
of i see that second one is one over
unit convert to kelvins
and the first one converts to kelvins
without a message
because it's it's just it's the same
temperature just you used an unusual
measurement device
right
so this is something that the users have
reported because there are formulas like
exponential of energy divided by kvt and
they want to put the t in degrees
celsius exactly that is probably one of
the most common things
looks nice
and these are basically cases where if
you explicitly insert an absolute
temperature into a compound unit
we will convert it to kelvin
automatically and give a warning that
you know if you meant degrees fahrenheit
difference you need to say degrees
fahrenheit difference
right just so i understand i mean this
whole business with
differences with whatever logarithmic
units how would they be treated in this
world of are they
what's what are the dimensions of of
bells for example the the
you know logarithmic units what are the
dimensions of logarithmic unit
depends which bell
well you could also argue they're not
really units
yeah i mean temperature scales share
some of these same problems in that
the vast majority of the units framework
makes assumptions about zero base and
linear relationship between units and uh
if we're going to talk about unit scales
or scale units we'll probably need a
separate meeting just because it it's a
whole can of worms but all right we
should we should have that yeah
just to answer quickly so bell plays the
role of kilo or mega it's just a
numerical factor
so it's it's you need to specify bell of
what and that determines the units
the the sorry dimensions it's again you
have a measurement device that shows you
your value in on a logarithmic scale but
it's still the same thing you measure
right so it's like a scaling function
but it is yeah
okay so i i didn't really realize that
one should think about it like the
prefixes and so on it's it's a scaling
function relative to something do you
need also
with respect to what
right is a digital parameter you need
i i need to run along here but but um
okay so look we've unfortunately we've
got one meeting about graph scans i
think it'd be nice to look a little bit
more at these temperature things
although i would say this looks good
from what i can see this looks good it
fixes the issues that people complain
about most often to that real users
complain about so that's a plus that's a
good thing to do
all right well we've got more can you
sorry can you look at the ild addict
section real quick
it should be kind of short
no
takes thought i don't know okay
not sure
i don't know
okay we'll circle back to these another
time then
sounds good all right
thanks and uh see you guys soon